all right good morning
be seated everyone hope everyone had a
good evening
all right mr blankets you ready to
proceed yes
call your next witness please
defense calls lisa campo
all right lisa campbell please officers
[Music]
uh just remain standing for a minute
please place your left hand on the bible
raise your right hand my cold clip will
administer an oath to you do you swear
in the presence of almighty god that the
testimony goes to the court regarding
this matter shall be the truth no truth
and nothing but the truth yes please
state your name let's go your last name
for the record
lisa campo c-a-m-p-o
thank you all right have a seat miss
campo please keep your voice up nice and
loud that microphone only records it
does not in any way project your voice
in the courtroom if you don't understand
the question please indicate that i'll
have counsel rephrase all right very
good
mr blencus your witness
good morning
what do you do for a living
um as of today i'm retired
um
directing your attention back to uh
august 7th
um
what were you doing
i was working as a physician assistant
at marstown medical center and can you
give the jury a little bit of your
background
i was employed at morristown hospital
since 2009 i worked in the orthopedic
department
and covered orthopedic and orthopedic
trauma patients
directing your attention to
august 7
did you have an occasion to treat
michael barracell
uh
not that i recall but according to
the notes
yes
i'm going to show you
what's been marked
d
600-2
and i realized it's a couple years ago
can you uh take a look at those notes
and tell me whether or not
that refreshes your recollection as to
whether or not on august 7th
you were working and
treated michael barrasson
uh according to this uh yes i'm the
author of this note i was
present in a trauma room for a trauma
patient which arrived in the emergency
room
i was doing a consult for the orthopedic
surgeon who was on call for trauma
um
looks like at the time the patient came
in he was not identified
therefore the note says that the patient
is 119 year old unknown and that's
typical for someone who is a trauma
patient to come in until they are
identified at some point
down the road
all right so
whoever you were treating on that day
did you notice any uh
injuries to him
according to the note
the patient was complaining of elbow
pain
says that there was
multiple abrasions scratch marks about
the chest back and left elbow
with regards to the physical exam
and in talking to him um
what if anything did you know
i noted that the patient was awake um he
was only oriented times one which means
he
would recognize his name other than that
he was confused he
if he was not oriented more than times
one that means he really didn't know
where he was or what date it was at the
time of his arrival
i wrote in my note that he was
confused and speaking and complaining of
significant chest and left upper
extremity pain distress
did you notice any
puncture wounds on his body
according to my note it says there was a
puncture wound and scratches a left
along the left a dorsal elbow
and a a significantly obvious deformity
of the elbow
with regards to the chest what did you
observe
i see no obvious deformity there were
multiple scratches and abrasions and a
possible puncture wound in the left
flank
i've nothing further
cross-examination is campo you don't
specifically remember treating mr
barissa
no i did not no further questions
children
all right thank you ma'am you know
just one other question irrespective of
whether or not you remember whoever you
treated on that specific day
you observed what you've testified to
correct absolutely yes
all right you may step down miss campo
thank you
the next witness mr belinkas
audrey huber
audrey hubert
good morning good morning can you place
your left hand on the bible please raise
your right hand my core clerk will
administer the oath
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
please state your name us by your last
name for the record andrea everett huber
hub er thank you
have a seat man please keep your voice
up nice and loud
the microphone on the witness stand does
not project your voice at all it just
records it so we need to hear your
natural speaking voice
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
retrace all right very good
mr blankist your witness thank you good
morning
good morning
what do you do for a living
i am a director of a non-profit
organization in long valley the mbca
directing your attention to
august 7
2019 yes uh what were you doing
i believe you're referring to these
first aid squad call i'm a volunteer
member of the long valley first aid
squad
so
i was
going to the call okay and how long have
you been a member of
that first day uh to this point 18 years
18 years as of now now
all right so
approximately 16 years at the time
correct
and if you have any particular training
to be a first aid responder yes i'm a
certified emt
in the state of new jersey which means i
did
at the time i went through the class was
about 110 hours of training
uh 10 hours of volunteer time at the
hospital and we do continuing education
classes to recertify every two years
on that day
did you respond to
a 411
mill road
east or west mill yes okay and
when you got there did you have an
opportunity to observe
my client michael barrasso yes
oh did you treat him on that day yes
all right um
with regards to uh
your
primary your primary
impression
do you recall what that was at that day
may i look at my notes sure absolutely
well let me give you your report it's
defense 600-1
take a look at that see if that
refreshes your recollection we're gonna
be talking about certain things right
uh we got to the scene
um
there was a lot of activity
um
the person that came with me in my
ambulance went to treat the young lady
and ice
they had enough people there so i looked
over and saw mr barriston sitting
against a tree with an obvious facial
injury
okay
and did you observe any injury to his
arms
i saw that in the report yeah i did not
recall that before i read the report but
yes
now that you've read the request
what if anything you observed with
regards to his arm
that came a little bit later um
as i stated he was handcuffed at the
time
the initial
my initial observation was the blood
that was running down his face
the arm
we tended to a little bit later when two
members of the atlantic
ambulance squad came over because i
didn't have enough equipment there
and how would you describe what you
observed regarding his arm
i don't recall it was deformed
um
and we did splint it later
according to the report but i did not
it didn't stick out in my mind honestly
as much as the facial injury
do you recall seeing any injuries to the
inner
left thigh
there was it looked like a dog bite
and where was that located
um
in her left thigh along with various
lacerations
now
during your treatment of him
did you ask him what happened for the
purpose of
using that
as far as your assessment
i don't recall
do you recall him saying judgement
she doesn't recall
she can refresh her recollection you
can't just read from the report the
report's not in evidence can you uh
please look at your report yes sir and
i'm going to refer you to the second
paragraph in the narrative
did you ask repeated questions to mr
barroso
no sir he asked repeated questions to
the crew
okay and what do you say if anything
about the incident
i don't remember
clear i don't remember everything please
refer to your report and see if that
refreshes your recollection oh he
remembered his birthday at one point
he did not remember the incident
just so the record's clear mr polinkas
was pointing to a specific line in the
report it's to refresh a recollection
right reports not in evidence does it
refresh your recollection about
what he said regarding remembering the
incident
not really but if i wrote the report
it's true one okay okay i have nothing
further
mr shalhorn ms huber what does uh loc
stand for loss of consciousness
and did you indicate in your report on
the top section
that there was a head injury without
loss of consciousness correct
no further questions judge thank you
where was that information where did you
get that information from
that you put in your report that there
was a loss of consciousness we have
a um
system
where that we use for writing reports
and there's a drop down menu and that
best described
what the incident was
okay
but but specifically the uh you
indicated
there was not a loss of consciousness
not that i could no yes and is that is
that determination based on your
interaction with mr barrissone at the
scene or do you get that information
from other sources as well
to put in your report
i don't recall honestly your honor what
transpired as far as my asking your
questions it is a question we usually
ask but i don't recall specifically
asking it in this case
somehow i knew either somebody told me
or mr garrison himself told me okay all
right thank you
you can step down man thank you so much
for coming to court today
uh your next witness please
dr john
doctor john cassero
hi doctor good morning
can you place your left hand on the
bible please
and raise your right hand you can put
your pen and notes down that's it raise
your right hand my clerk will administer
enough
that the testimony yeah to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your name as for
your last name for the record yeah john
daniel bascara um
b-a-s-c-a-r-a
you may have a seat sir okay
please keep your voice up nice and loud
yes the microphone only records it does
not project your voice anymore okay all
right and if you don't understand the
question please indicate that i'll have
counsel
go ahead mr blancas
good morning doctor
where are you employed sir morris county
correctional facility in what capacity
i'm the uh the jail psychiatrist
and how long have you been with john
since uh january 2016.
now
can you give the jury a little bit of
your background
your education and experience
prior to
august 2019 yes i completed my
uh psychiatry training in 2004 and at
thomas jefferson university
and
in 2006 i finished my
uh child and ls and psychiatry training
at
new jersey medical school here
directing your attention to august 20th
2019
did you have an occasion to uh
talk to my client michael barrisson yes
yes
and and
what was the purpose of that uh
discussion oh
uh it was um i was referred uh by the
staff
uh because um
this guy if i refer to my notes yeah who
had been complaining of stuff
did you um author a report doctor
oh based on your interactions with the
defendant yes and was that done
uh around the same time
contemporaneously with your interactions
with the defense yeah after i saw it yes
and do you need that to refresh your
recollection about specifics of your
interaction with the defendant yes i
have a copy or two okay all right we're
going to have that has it been marked mr
balance just for reference uh for the
record yes
what's the exhibit number 600-6
okay
as a psychiatrist
um
did you ask michael barrasson about the
events
that occurred on
august 7th 2019.
um
yes yes was he able to remember or
respond
to your questions regarding the actual
event
well um
he told me that he couldn't recall what
happened
no further question
mr shalhorn ending cross
dr bascara can you describe the nature
of your examination
was it a forensic examination
no was it a clinical examination yes yes
yes and and how did you gather the
information that you needed to treat
michael barrasson on august 20th oh uh
we just met in the examination room and
um
as as based on
his self report his
the interview and based on your
conversations with him did you note any
delusions with this thinking
uh no no no
did you mention anything during the
course of the interview with you about
being fearful or scared
yeah let me just refer down
uh
he just each said that his he had been
very nervous you know his mind was
racing whatever
yes
did you note in your report uh that he
was acting apparently impulsively with
this recent violent behavior
well this that's also based on the
report just uh of what he told me
what happened
right so so you wrote that based on what
he told you yes you you indicated that
he had apparently acted impulsively and
violently
oh did i put that in my mouth
yes yeah yes
where it says diagnosis
what does that mean where it says rule
out amnesia due to head trauma
no it's just
because one of of the two complaints one
was anxiety the other one was
forgetfulness just a
just a
you know a possible explanation for what
he's saying
no further questions judge
all right
any redirect mr malinkas
you may step down doctor thank you
members of the jury did anyone have
trouble
hearing any of that testimony
what was it the entire testimony or just
parts of it
yeah
very soft-spoken
you want to bring them back and have it
uh repeated mr shellhorn the jurors
indicated that in here the last couple
of questions he answers
i would certainly defer to the jury if
they want him to come back otherwise i
think the
they can certainly ask for that to be
replayed if there's any question during
the course of their deliberations
unless they wanted to come back we can
have him come back now that he's here or
everything's recorded so if you need to
hear it we can have it replay during
your deliberations i i leave it up to
you how would you like to proceed
i'm happy
okay
it is all the testimony is recorded
you've heard me say that a number of
times so and if you need any specifics
of testimony during deliberations you
can always ask for a playback and we'll
have it played back okay
yes
your next witness
thomas fellini corporal thomas fellini
hi corporal good morning uh please place
your left hand on the bible raise your
right hand my court clerk will
administer a note do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony of this court regarding this
matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
please state your name must be your last
name for the record thomas twelini
last name is african frank a l e ni
thank you
all right corporal have a seat please
keep your voice up nice and loud
we have jurors in the first two rows
that need to hear that microphone
doesn't project your voice it just
records it so okay they need to hear
your natural speaking voice all right mr
blinkist go ahead
washington township police department
and how long have you been employed
20 years
directing your attention to
august
7
2019
were you the affiant
of a search warrant concerning this case
yes it was can you can you explain to
the jury what an action is
an atheist is um
an officer who collects all the
information from the incident that
occurred
responds to the prosecutor's office
fills out an affidavit
stating what uh
what is required to investigate the
incident
and
we draw up
an affidavit warrant
and a judge reviews that
signs that and that enables us to
collect the evidence we need to
do our investigation
now in this particular case
you were
conferring and consulting with the
morris county prosecutor's office
correct correct
and and after that consult
you swore to and submitted your
affidavit correct correct
now um
did you request uh to search any vehicle
based on
the information that you had had
yes uh what vehicle and who did it
belong to
it was uh
can i refer to my absolutely i'm going
to give you a copy we'll have a more
copy given to you for the record
that's a copy of
yes it is
what if any vehicles
did you request to be searched
that's the um
the silver dodge ram pickup
with the florida registration
and why did you include that in your app
today
it belonged to
the suspect
mr barrison
and
were you aware
that there were
two other vehicles and a trailer
parked in the immediate area
close to michael barrison's vehicle yes
did you attempt to get a warrant to
search those vehicles
no we did not
did you request to search
various telephones
yes
telephones were then
there was a black
samsung galaxy s7 who did that belong to
based on your knowledge
uh robert goodwin
any others oh yes it was a white iphone
with a pink case
believed to be uh belonged to lauren
canorack
and then there was a white iphone with
no case
um
weren't sure who that belonged to was in
the area of the incident
it was in
another iphone that was taken from
mary haskins gray at police headquarters
did you request the swapping
of any person's hand
for gunshot wrestling
um
yes
yes
and
whose hands did you request
he suave
um michael barrison
and why did you
request
that michael barristone's hands be
swabbed for gunshot residue
due to information at the scene
um we were
advised that he was the shooter
and and what does gunshot resident would
have to do with michael barrasson's
hands if anything
it would
prove that he had shot a weapon
did you ask to swab
any other person's hands
on that day no
to your knowledge was any gunshot
residue has been done on anyone in this
case
no
i don't believe so
now
in your affidavit
you put information that you received
from various witnesses correct yes
and is it correct
that you indicated that goodwin only has
already
let me see inside
corporal did you talk to robert goodwin
yes
and did
robert goodwin tell you
that he only heard again
again this is your witness
you can't lead your witness
what did robert goodwin tell you with
regards to
whether or not he actually saw versus
hearing
the gunshot
i have in my affidavit basically what he
had uh
stated to me that day
about him he was on the porch
and
he turned to enter the residence
and heard a gunshot and turned
back
and looked
after him back or turned around
turned around
turned to walk back into the residence
reportedly uh
lauren can iraq walked over to speak to
paris by whether this is refreshing his
memory or whether he is it appears he's
reading and i don't know if that's from
his memory or not
are you i'm i'm referring to my report
to refresh your memory or do you have no
recollection of it you're just reading
from the right there's a difference i
was just reading i'm sorry my
recollection would be that he
explained to me that
he turned to go back into the residence
and then
heard the gunshot turned back and
observed
uh mr barrisson
shooting or
no further questions
cross-examination
yes sir and that's a copy of the
affidavit that you submitted to judge
ironson on august
7
2019. correct is the information
contained in that based on a full and
complete investigation
it's it was a quick investigation at the
time in order to get the information i
needed to
quickly obtaining from
the rest of the information through the
affidavit in other words you can't
conduct any search at the property until
the judge authorizes a search warrant
yes correct so you didn't take the time
to conduct a full and complete
investigation before you submitted this
to the judge it was just based on what
you knew at the time that's correct
now you were just asked some questions
about speaking to robert goodwin
yes where did you speak to him
i was in front of my patrol vehicle at
the scene
and can you describe what your
recollection of the
scene was was it chaotic yes were there
a number of police officers there yes
both from washington township and other
agencies correct
i believe chester one of the chester
police departments was there at the time
i believe so uh
the morris county sheriff's office
correct a number of different ambulance
companies
yes
and
did you see ms kanarek had been shot
yes did you see her receiving medical
treatment at the scene yes how would you
describe mr goodwin's
emotional state at the time you were
talking to him
um
i i was tending to miss kanorak when i
first got there um
and when she was taken away is when i
went to talk to mr goodwin
during my care of miss kanorak he was
frantic trying to get to her and one of
officers was
basically holding him back and speaking
with him to keep him away so we can care
to her
at the time that you were speaking to
him at the scene in front of your patrol
car
was he somewhat difficult to follow what
he was saying
uh yes he was still frantic she was on
her way to the hospital and he just
wanted to get to her
did uh did you record that statement
uh no i don't please sir uh are you
aware that he was taken from
the scene back to the police department
for a formal recorded statement yes
i think you were also asked the question
about
making an application for
a search warrant
or permission to search specifically the
silver pickup truck
correct and was that based on
information you received during the
course of that limited investigation
that michael garrosone had driven to the
scene in that pickup truck yes
in your affidavit did you
ask in paragraph five
for
authorization to search
any other items relevant to the
investigation and crimes described
herein that a complete and thorough
search will reveal
yes so you didn't list every single item
vehicle location on that 50 acre
property
in this search warrant affidavit no i
did not
just based on what you knew at the time
you applied for the search warrant that
afternoon what you
were specifically aware of that needed
to be searched correct
no further questions judge thank you
what any redirect yes
corporal with regards to this catch-all
phrase the prosecutor just uh
brought to your attention to your
knowledge did you ever search robert
goodwin's vehicles for his trailer
no
to my knowledge i
did not even though technically you
could
based on
well
let me see that side more
is it your understanding
that
you can search
a vehicle
unless it's specifically
mentioned in a war
what's your understanding you're talking
about the the the current application
you're talking not not generally just
he's asking you about the current search
warrant affidavit and the warrant that
you received the one that i received
that gave you the authority to search
robert goodwin's two vehicles
and the trailer on the property yes
to your knowledge were they searched
that i could not tell you
um
did you did you
[Music]
seize the camera
that was looking directly
at the location objection yeah you
missed mister blinkers
just just ask a question don't
editorialize please did you put in the
affidavit to search things and seize
things
any cameras
yes
to your knowledge did they seize any
cameras
no
nothing further
you may step down thank you this is uh
yes just think that the council will
retrieve
your
it
i'm going to get this
[Music]
here's this oh thank you
you're honored the defense calls jamie
dancer jamie dancer
can we be heard at sidebar sure
yes
all right uh we'll call the witness
officer if you would uh miss jamie
dancer
amen just made standing for a moment
left hand on the bible if you would
raise your right hand it's an idiot do
you swore in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your
nameless spell your last name for the
record jamie dancer
d-a-n-c-e-r thank you all right have a
seat miss dancer please keep your voice
up nice and loud in response to
questions that microphone does not
project your voice it only records if
you don't understand the question please
indicate that i'll have it rephrased go
ahead counsel thank you ron
miss dancer good morning good morning do
you live in new jersey i do where
millstone township uh and are you an
athlete
i am in what sport dressage and how long
have you been a dressage athlete
since i was seven so
30 some odd years and could you give the
jury a brief summary of your
accomplishments in that field
um
i'm a usdf
bronze silver gold medalist and
i've recently started competing
internationally
um
did there come a time when you became
acquainted with michael barrisson
yes and what year if you recall
approximately was that
2003
and
what was the nature of your acquaintance
with him in 2003 going forward if you
could summarize that for the jury
i first started working for him as a
working student um
and then after that i started my own
business and
um would continue to ride with michael
and ship up to his farm in new jersey
and also down in florida with him
did you train with him as a rider
yes
did your horse train with him yes
in connection with that training was any
of it accomplished at the farm in long
valley yes
uh did you live at the farm
at points yes
so let's fast forward to 2019 were you
living at the farm at that time no
were you still training with him yes and
was your horse still being trained by
his business yes
uh and then any part of that training
was it conducted by other people that
worked in the business
no okay
so
you knew michael as a trainer correct
yes did you know him in any other
capacity given your involvement with him
over those years
we're friends and he's my mentor
based upon your friendship with michael
over the years do you believe you
developed an understanding of
what he was like under normal
circumstances yes could you describe for
the jury what michael barason was like
under normal circumstances yes
he was very clean cut
shirt always tucked in felt
um
everything was always clean and
immaculate everywhere
um
fun to be around
um
yet
when it came to the riding very intense
and precise
um
i
yeah
based upon your years of experience
knowing michael barrison did you have a
chance to observe him working with
horses yes did you ever witness him and
in any manner mistreating a horse
no
given your experience with him over
those years did you ever
observe him being violent toward a human
being
absolutely not
were you on the farm in early august
2019
yes were you coming and going in
connection with your training yes
uh during those days well are you aware
that an incident occurred on august 7th
of the fall yes are you aware that there
was a shooting
yes okay
uh
prior to the shooting is the next series
of questions that's what i'm going to
ask about okay
um were you observing
michael barrasson's
behavior at all in the days leading up
to the shooting yes
how is he acting in comparison to the
michael that you knew from all of those
years before
he was very upset he was distraught
um i was very concerned he was going to
harm himself
when you say harm himself in what way
were you concerned that michael barrison
was going to harm himself i thought he
was going to kill
himself did his appearance change at all
in those days leading up to the incident
yes what changed about his physical
appearance
he was pacing
he wasn't as he did like his shirt
wasn't all the way tucked in
um
no belt
um
like
uh
sorry i just need a minute take as much
time as you need um
just not him he wasn't him he was it was
hard
to talk to him i was
concerned about him was he less
communicative than before
yes did he look disheveled in any way
personally in his appearance yes
then you say pacing tell me more about
the pacing that you saw
um
it was like neurotic it was like
neurotic pacing it i can only compare it
to horses um which
they pace when they're stressed and they
and they're looking and they're
searching and they're just unsettled
based upon what you observe with michael
barrasson did you come to any
conclusions as to whether he was
stressed
yes he was stressed and did you come to
any conclusions in your own mind as to
how you felt the degree of stress that
michael was under at that time extremely
high extremely high
as a result of your observations of
michael or pardon me let me back up for
a second
did you make any of these observations
of michael the day before the shooting
which would have been august 6 2019 yes
and as a result of your observations and
what your concerns were did you take any
action
i did what did you do
i called my good friend ali brock all
right and i don't want you to talk about
what was said on the conversation okay
okay
so
you talked to ali brock
yes uh and did you walk away from that
conversation with any understanding as
to whether ali brock was going to take
any action yes and what was your
understanding that you walked away from
that conversation with objection
what's the nature of your objection mr
shellhorn here's a judge or call spray
here say response
objection sustained
uh questions withdrawn
had you uh based upon your observations
on august 6th of 2019 had you ever
before in your association with michael
barrisson seen him in such a state
no
i have no further questions of the
witness very good cross-examination mr
shellhorn ms dancer you weren't at the
farm on august 7 2019 were you no you
don't have any personal knowledge of
what happened on that day no no further
questions judge thank you what
no redirection you may step down miss
dancer thank you
[Music]
our next witness i'd like to call is
allison brock all right
allison brock please
hi miss brock
please remain standing for a moment
place your left hand on the bible raise
your right hand
do you so in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony that to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your name
and spell your last name for the record
allison brock b-r-o-c-k thank you all
right you may have a seat miss brock
witness has been sworn
counsel direct examination
good morning miss brock
good morning
um where do you reside what state
i'm in florida
and uh
uh
what town in florida
uh specifically loxahatchee okay
and um uh are you an athlete i am in
what sport uh in the sport of dressage
and how long have you been a dressage
athlete oh
25 years
at least
and um could you give the jury a brief
summary of your accomplishments in that
sport
yes
i was a member of the 2016
rio olympic team for dressage for the
u.s and we won a bronze medal
so i've competed internationally
at the highest level
was that team usa yes
was michael barristone associated at all
with that team yes what was his
association with that team he was my
coach and uh prior to him coaching you
with that event how long had you known
michael barrisson i met michael in 2002
and in what capacity did you
first start interacting with michael i
actually um i lived on his farm in 2002
i was working for susan blanks who
was another olympian
and
she was in the process of going through
the selection trials for the 2002 world
equestrian games i was a working student
we had horses at michael's farm
ahead of the selection trials
your familiarity with michael
did it start in in some capacity where
he was training you
not at that time i didn't start training
with michael until 2010. okay but i
lived on the farm so
i was there
on and off that
summer did you know justin very well
when i got back i went to europe with
sue and when i got back justin just
started working for michael
so starting in 2010 that's when you
began to train with mr barrisson yes
uh and uh
how long after that did you continue to
train with him really through 2016
and then my
top horse
um
was injured in rio and never came back
and i had a bunch of young horses so
i would see michael here and there but i
wasn't training like i was leading up to
the olympic games
did you also get to know michael in any
capacity other than as a trainer yes uh
i would consider michael
a close friend
um
in uh
august of 2019
uh where were you physically located i
was actually
driving back from a vacation with my
family in the keys
and
at that point in time let's just bring
it to august of 2019.
did you receive a phone call from jamie
dancer
i did
i'm not going to ask you to tell us what
words were spoken in that call
because it will result in an objection
so the questions i'm asking you please
do not interpret that they that you need
to respond in specific words
all right
so you spoke to jamie dancer that day
yes do you recall approximately how long
the phone conversation lasted
um i
it was a couple minutes because i was in
the car with my family and i didn't want
to have a discussion
with them in the car
did you take any action as a result of
your conversation with miss dancer i did
as what did you do as soon as we got
home and i could separate myself
privately
i called michael did you have any
particular concern that drove you to
call michael that day absolutely what
was your concern based on
what jamie had said to me and
and texted me
um i was very concerned that michael was
going to kill himself
so you got michael on the phone
yes
without telling us what words were
spoken how was michael when he first got
on the phone
well he was quiet which
was very unlike
michael
and started to
tell me about objection judge
try not to get into the words of the
subject
so he was quiet at first
and then
proceeded to
[Music]
get more upset
and then was sobbing
hysterically
by the end of the phone call
were you able to calm him down at all no
in the past had you viewed michael in
circumstances when he was upset
yes but nothing
nothing like this you anticipated my
next question
based upon your years of knowledge and
experience working with michael and
knowing him as a person had you ever
seen him
in the state he was
or a partner seeing's probably not the
right word had you ever encountered him
in the state he was
as of that phone call now
no further questions at this time
cross-examination mr shellhorn ms brock
you're a member of the board of
directors for the u.s equestrian
federation i am and you're a member of a
number of different committees with the
respect to that association attention
beyond the scope of direct
ghost of a background which you elicited
in some detail council i'll allow it
uh ms brock you were not in new jersey
in august of 2019 no you were not at the
farm on august 7 2019 no and you have no
personal knowledge of what happened that
day no judge i have no further questions
thank you what
no redirect your honor you may step down
ma'am thank you
[Music]
what next witness
sean cullen
sean colin please to the stand
[Music]
uh place your left hand on the bible
please
raise your right hand
please listen to the oath do you swear
in the presence of almighty god that the
testimony goes to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
yes i do please state your name and
spell your last name for the record sure
full name of sean cohen last name is
c-u-l-l-e
thank you all right you may have a seat
mr cohen please keep your voice up nice
and loud you can remove your mask if you
want to i leave that entirely up to you
but if you keep your mask on you're
going to have to speak
that much louder so we have jurors in
the first two worlds
all right very good thank you my nose
no not at all
all right mr cullen has been sworn go
ahead sir
atlantic um distance
and can you give the jury a little bit
of your background
sure i'm a licensed professional
counselor within the state of new jersey
my degree is in account master's in
counseling psychology
i've worked in behavioral health for
just a little over 20 years now
and i have an extensive history of doing
uh
psych valves interviews in er settings
and and
where did you go to school
coldwell university
now directing your attention to uh
august 9th
did you have an occasion to uh
uh meet and talk with my client michael
barrisson yes
and at any
point in time
did you try to ask some specific
questions
regarding the event
in question
specific questions no
not about the event
okay did he make any statements with
regards to the specific event yes what
did he say
he spoke as was cited in my
documentation he spoke about the
stressors of the event
some aspects in the days before the
event
to my recollection and what's in my
documentation do not recall the
immediate events that result in his
being in the hospital
nothing
cross-examination
thank you judge
mr cullen uh when you met with the
defendant on august uh
9th of 2019
did he indicate to you
that he had told the police that
things at his farm were going to come to
a boiling point
i believe that was a quote in my
documentation from that day from that
interview with him
and if i judge if i could just approach
briefly
with his report yes sir all right what's
the marking on it as s 84
pages 35 and 37 of s84
mr cullen that report is just to refresh
your recollection at this point just
take a look at it tell us if you
recognize what that document is
yes your honor is that a report that you
authored that is correct you recall the
date you authored the report yes
and does that uh in essence summarize
your interactions with mr barristone on
august 9th yes
thank you
go ahead
and
mr cullen directing your attention i
believe it's uh about a quarter of the
way or a third of the way down that
first page
did you put that excuse me probably a
little bit further down the page than
that did you put that in quotation marks
uh that this was going to come to a
boiling point
judge i object i yesterday read the
entire sentence it's out of context
again
just object mr blinker i don't like
mr cullen i think the question i asked
you was uh if you could read the direct
quote that michael barrasson told you
from your report if that refreshes your
memory
certainly the direct quote in quotations
as i kept telling him this was going to
come to a boiling point
now did he also didn't he also tell you
on that day that his significant other
didn't feel safe
uh that is correct that's also in the
documentation there's a quote for that
as well he never told you anything about
he himself not feeling safe
to the best of my recollection that was
not quoted directly to me
did he also tell you that around the
time of the shooting that
dcp or child protection was at the
property
yes according to my documentation the
wisdom noted to be the morning prior the
dcp were present and did he tell you
that there was a specific
reason that dcp would he was there was
for a call pertaining to the care of his
girlfriend's children
to the best of my recollection he
mentioned that he felt that someone had
called them making possible accusations
as they arrived due to concerns to
investigate
did you note
that he said to you a number of times
that there was a steady building of
stressors in his life
yes that is noted in my documentation
and i believe if i refer you to page
three
did you indicate that he noted several
acute stressors in the 48 hours
preceding
his admission to the hospital
yes that's correct
but he didn't specifically note that
fear was one of those stressors
not specifically in my right to my
recollection not that i quoted in the
report
last question mr cullen uh you found
mr barrissone's thought content to be
unremarkable for delusional distortions
that's correct
judge no further questions thank you all
right any redirect yes
with regards to the quote
that the prosecutor read you regarding
uh
i kept telling them
this was going to come to a boiling
point
who did he indicate to you
that he was
telling this to
several times
the local police department
were you given information that he
possibly
had ptsd
ptsd is listed in quotes in the
documentation
for the service i work on the
psychiatric counsel service when a
physician puts in a consul order they
always put a rationale for that order
that was the initial rationale by the
medical team
and
did they also
indicate that there was a complaint of
loss
of consciousness
that was also that's quoted in in my
documentation that comes from the
medical notes
with multiple trauma status correct that
is correct
is there any
notes with regards to a left elbow
dislocation
judge i'm going to object that this is
beyond the scope of the
cross
cross-examination
it is somewhat details of the report i'm
sorry
got into the details of the report
which i did not direct and now i believe
i can
bring out other details based on his
cross
all right i'll allow it
overall
did it indicate that there was multiple
traumas to michael
per my documentation the medical
documentation yes
open reduction left elbow dislocation
correct
that is correct that's from the medical
documentation
something further
anything further mr horn
mr cullen you may step down thank you
let's watch your stuff
thank you please
so
all right call your next witness
your honor the defense clause jordan
osborne
jordan osborne please
place your left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand
please listen to the oath
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony you give to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes i do please state your
name for your last name for the record
jordan osborne
osborne thank you all right ms osborne
you can have a seat please keep your
voice up nice and loud
that microphone does not project your
voice in the courtroom it just records
it so the jurors in the first two rows
and then the jury box have to hear your
natural voice all right thank you if you
don't understand the question please
indicate that and i'll have counsel
rephrase
what
this is
i'm good how are you i'm well thank you
for asking
um as of uh august 2019 how old were you
i was 16. you were 16 years old and uh
did you uh
live at the farm in long valley where
michael barrasson operated his business
yes i did
and what did you do there
just in general that summer i was a
working student so i wrote and i helped
take care of the horses
and so give us an idea of what your
daily regime was in in life back in
those days um we'd get up and we'd feed
the horse's breakfast and then by then
it was time for everyone to ride so we'd
help get horses ready we'd ride our own
horses
we'd then we'd feed lunch keep riding
eat dinner and then just normal regular
barn chores cleaning things up
were there other students living there
as well yes
and who were they
um there was chelsea westra
and mike mike mcgrain and cassandra
defranco
and then justin was there as the
assistant trainer
and um was cassandra a student or did
she have some other capacity there um
she was a barn manager so with
everything taking care of the barn and
the horses she was in charge of that
and were you aware uh that there were
other people living at the farm in the
farmhouse in the summer of 2019. yes i
was who were they lauren cantrack and
rob goodwin
and did you interact with them at all on
a regular basis yes i did
you're on a request to approach the
witness sure
i'd like to show you a photo
which has been marked as d
800-90.
do you see the photo yes
who is it a photo of that's rob goodwin
and
does this photo
depict
goodwin's appearance as you understood
it to be back in august of 2019 yes
i move 800-90 in evidence
objection
i'm not sure what the relevance
all right the objection is sustained
move on to another area council
did lauren cantarek and robert goodwin
have a dog
and did you interact with the dog at all
not physically
hold on
we may have a problem with courtsmart
that's the recording
all right go ahead counsel
just re-ask your question please
did you interact directly with the dog
not physically but i saw the dog a lot
i'd like to approach
i've shown you i'm going to show you
what's been marked for identification as
defense exhibit 800-90
exact picture
and uh in your mind an accurate picture
of the dog
yes what was the dog's name
uh rosie were you scared of the dog yeah
connection
what's the relevance of this
while you were on the farm uh commencing
in the period of the end of july we'll
say july 31st
uh through august 6th
uh were you aware of whether or not the
police were called to the farm on a
number of occasions yes and did you ever
talk to the police when they were at the
farm yes i did
when you talked to the police
did you observe their reaction to what
you were telling them
yes
and what reaction did you observe of the
police when you told them
the information you gave
they were very
nonchalant and they just turned around
and walked away
did you ever feel threatened by robert
goodwin uh objection judge we just
talked about this all right members of
the jury we're going to take our all
morning break now
[Music]
you can step off the stand
just watch your step
[Music]
[Music]
my counsel uh will be stricken from the
record it was an improper question that
he asked
well please don't consider it in any way
the witness's state of mind is not an
issue in this case
mr barrison's state of mind is an issue
not the witnesses so please ignore that
question it was improper and it's
stricken from the record
all right let's call the witness back in
you may have a seat miss osborne
all right council i have no further
questions of miss osborne at this time
any cross-examination briefly judge
ms osborne good morning good morning
have you ever testified in court before
no all right
uh is your mother lara osborne yes
what's the nature of her relationship
with michael barason at this point i'm
there in a romantic relationship
hold on is there an objection counsel i
objected to relevance
church this clearly goes towards bias
this was explored on cross-examination
with state witnesses
i'm sorry there was an objection could
you just tell the jury again what your
last answer was they're in a romantic
relationship thank you no further
questions josh
thank you
you swore under oath to tell the truth
when you brought here this morning yes
would you violate that oath simply
because of a relationship your mother
was having absolutely not thank you no
further questions oh you may step down
man thank you
for your next witness the defense calls
mary
defranco mary defranco
just watch her step and step out
i'm mr franco
please remain standing for a moment
place your left hand on the bible raise
your right hand listen to the oath
please jesus so in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony good to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth yes please state your name
mr last name for the record mary
defranco
d-e-f-r-a-n-c-o thank you all right you
can have a seat matt please keep your
voice up nice and loud so all the jurors
can hear your answers that microphone
does not
project your voice and only records it
okay all right very good if you don't
understand the question please indicate
that i'll have council rephrase go ahead
council
um miss defranco uh
do you live in illinois i do
what town crystal lake
um
what is your educational background
i have a bachelor's degree in finance
and a master's in finance and economics
so a bachelor's degree and a master's
yes
uh
what do you do for a living
i'm in data and intelligence services i
do data standardization for a large
financial institution
and you do that in illinois i do
uh do you pursue any
hobbies related to the horse world i do
what hobbies do you pursue i'm an
amateur enthusiast um for dressage
how long have you been pursuing that
um dressage probably the last 10 years
but i was doing 100 jumper sports before
that so all in all about 25 years
and in connection with your pursuit of
that have you
taken any lessons or training over the
years yes
tell us about that
um so i have taken dressage lessons on a
regular basis um i have my horse in
training as well as myself
so i probably take um
three lessons a week and then ride
independently twice a week and over how
long of a time period have you been
pursuing training
10 years
um you mentioned your horse are you also
a horse owner yes i am and over your
association with this hobby how many
times how many horses have you owned
oh my over the years or currently over
the years over the years
over a dozen over a dozen
um
is your daughter also involved in in any
way in the horse world yes she is what's
her involvement she is also a dressage
writer
um she rides as a professional
oh she's a professional okay
and um
uh
let's go back to uh
well let me ask you this first um
do you know michael barrison i do
how long have you known him
since 2016. so almost four years i'm
sorry since 2016. so six years almost
and in what capacity did you become
introduced to michael barrison my
daughter was interested in training with
him in the summer of 2016 after the
olympics
and she contacted him
and that's how we met
was her interest at all uh inspired by
what happened in the rio olympics that
year of course
and so did your daughter come to uh
start working with michael yes she did
and did you also over the years work
with michael yes i came frequently for
to both to visit my daughter and then um
most recently take lessons as well okay
and so um
the fact that you took lessons with
michael is that the only capacity in
which you knew him when you were
actually in the arena taking lessons or
did you come to know him in other
contexts i consider michael a friend
and how long have you considered michael
to be a friend since i've met him okay
now
did your daughter become employed at
michael's barn
she did um when we when she came to um
michael's in 2016 she was a client
and she was a client through
that
2016-2017 season in florida
and it was in the spring of 2017 that
she became
a working student for michael
and um
as a working student did she live at the
farm she did
was she living at the farm in the summer
of 2019 yes and did she board her her
horse there yes did she have more than
one horse there yes she did how many she
had two
uh and
did there come a time in 2019
when you uh made a new acquisition with
with respect to your hobby i did i
bought a new horse a young one in the in
june of 2019.
and um uh
was that horse brought by you or on your
behalf to michael's farm yes i had my
horse shipped to michael's farm um in
the middle of july july 15 16 something
like that of 2019. and why did you have
your horse shipped there for training
okay
so is training of the horse separate
from training of the rider sometimes um
my horse was four so he was a baby
and uh i'm an amateur older lady adult
and i shipped him there to start his
training and
so that he would become more
confident and safe for me
based on on your understanding of how
the farm operated at that time in june
of 2019
was there a person who was
specifically assigned to train young
horses
not to my knowledge
did you know an individual there named
mike mcgrane yes
and what was his role at the farm if you
know oh yes so mike actually rode
very young horses so horses that were
not accustomed to even having a saddle
on them yet um they were they were very
untrained so my horse was a little
further along than that so the horse
that you purchased as a four-year-old
wasn't going to be trained by mr mcgrane
no
who was training your horse at that time
my daughter
my daughter your daughter was okay and
when it came to to uh
your training uh in the summer of 2019
did you have a regular schedule as when
you come to new jersey
yes um the plan was for me to be in new
jersey two weeks out of every month
i would come
during those two weeks ride and train on
my horse and then go back to illinois
for two weeks and while i was gone um
the horse would be in training
and uh uh
who was training you and your horse at
michael's farm that summer
um i took a couple lessons from michael
i took a couple lessons from justin
and
how did you
uh have any impression of the quality of
training you were receiving from justin
for example it was excellent
no complaints none
did there come a time in july of 2019
when you made one of those
two-week visits
yes
and do you recall the precise date you
arrived and when you were supposed to
leave
um
precisely arrival no um i would have
arrived somewhere around the 15th or the
16th
and i was scheduled to leave though on
the 31st
okay so you came to the farm in july at
or about that time period
and
is there anything in particular you
observed at the farm at that time
it was um
not as happy a place as it used to be
okay and could you be a little more
descriptive as to what indicated to you
that it wasn't as happy and of a place
as it used to be
it there was a lot of tension in the air
it was very stressful
the
michael's demeanor was
not as
it used to be not as engaging he was he
was elsewhere in his mind
um
there were
other borders who were
definitely
you know also
tense and um lots of conversation around
the
just the feeling in in the barn that it
just wasn't right
did you make any observations about your
daughter at that time when you came to
the farm and noticed that things weren't
right
she was equally tons if not more i
actually was very concerned about her
when i arrived what concerns did you
have about your daughter specifically
with respect to what was going on at the
farm at that time i think
when i arrived if i remember correctly
she was very concerned
about
the horses
about the safety
of the horses she was concerned that
the schedule was getting very disruptive
in the barn because of
just
just the the cadence of things in the
barn you know my daughter worked there
so in the morning there's there's
feeding and then there's watering and
then there's turnout but because of all
the all the tension and the chaos that
was going on at the time um that it all
had been up ended and so she was quite
stressed out about all that well you had
your new four-year-old there yes correct
did you have any concerns with respect
to your new horse
um
at first i was i thought no everything's
fine and then within a few days i could
tell that things weren't going well um
the again the attention of the barn was
too high i started having concerns about
safety myself both for myself and my
daughter as well as the horses
when you say you had concerns about
safety
what specifically were your concerns
well there was um the the tension that
was going on was because that there was
a client there
um that was being problematic
and um menacing and harassing
um to to michael mary haskins
and i believe even justin
and it got to the point that that was
bleeding over
into the the culture of the barn as well
as
into the the process of taking care of
the horses so i was worried that you
know
something was going to happen to them in
the middle of the night or
you know when i when we weren't there
so it was just
not a pleasant place to be
as a result of what you observed what
your concerns were and what you were
experiencing
did you start making any plans with
respect to where to board your horse and
your daughter's horses oh absolutely so
as the days continued during my visit
um my daughter and i discussed that you
know we needed to move the horses um we
needed to get out of that environment it
was too menacing and harassing i wasn't
happy and i was just as disturbed i
think as everyone else about what was
happening there
luckily um the barn is located in an
area where you can drive you know 15
minutes in any direction and there's
there's lots of horse funds
so we were looking for you know safe and
clean and just just to get out of what i
was perceiving to be a um
not so safe environment
as a result of your presence uh at the
facility um were you familiar with the
locker area of the barn yes of course
okay
i'm going to show you what was marked
for identification as 800-42
you have before your photograph
does this well what is it a photograph
of so this is the locker area as you
step the white door um represents the
door that would lead into the club room
so if you were walking out of the club
room and stepping down those few steps
you'd be in the in the locker area where
boarders would have their personal items
uh based upon your personal observations
at the at the farm does this picture
accurately depict the layout of the
lockers and the walls at the time yes
uh move
800-42 in evidence
no objection judge what
800-42 defense exhibit is admitted into
evidence
based upon your uh
well you were physically in this space
correct
on a number of occasions yes on a
regular basis yes
okay uh was there a bench there
here in this in this area yeah
i'm sorry i don't know if your answer
was no i'm sorry no there was no bench
so you're looking at a photograph where
the lockers are and you're saying that
there's no bench in that area when
you're counsel
you don't need to repeat the answer okay
every question all right the jury hears
it i'm certain
so just ask your follow-up question
please i will
um
did you have um and i don't want you to
talk about the words that were spoken
okay but did you have private
conversations
uh with michael barissone
or other people at the farm
about the tensions that you were
observing yes
and
did you have those private conversations
in a particular location
multiple locations
uh did you ever have conversations like
that
um
in the office yes
did you ever have conversations like
that in the club room yes
did there come a time when you developed
a concern
that someone was listening to those
private conversations that wasn't
present participating in them yes
and
when did you develop that concern with
respect to what was happening at the
farm
when my own words verbatim were repeated
by someone who would not have been there
and
posted in social media
do you recall
without saying what the words were do
you recall where you were
physically when you spoke those words
michael's office okay and who was
present when you spoke those words mary
haskins anyone else no
how far is the office from the locker
area if you recall
has to be 100
feet okay
and did you then
i'm sorry did you say that you your
words were posted on social media yes
who posted them lauren kanrak
so
when you were there
uh from the period of well you were
there from the period of july 31st
through the time the incident occurred
correct yes
and in fact you were there the day of
the incident yes and you were
interviewed by the police and and other
people after the incident yes okay
were you
present when police were called
to the farm before the incident yes
did you
observe
michael barisson in the days leading up
to the incident
yes uh at that point in time how many
years had you known him
three
did you see
any changes in michael's behavior in the
days leading up to the incident yes what
did you see
he was falling apart
he came became completely distraught
just
completely distraught not himself
worried
very
just i would describe it as terrified of
of
living in his own home i mean he was
terrified
did you develop any concerns for
yourself when you saw michael in this
condition yes
did that add to the concerns you had for
your safety the safety of your daughter
and the safety of your animals yes
who which persons were the source
of your concern
lauren canreck and robert goodwin
did you have a chance to observe whether
or not
michael barrasson
uh
interacted with lauren canorack or
robert goodwin
alone
in those days leading up to the incident
he never wanted to be alone with them
in fact it was he went out of his way to
not be alone with them
he was terrified of them we i was
terrified of them
and so
because of all of the postings that were
going on on social media the
the this is non-responsive
it it is somewhat just ask another
question please
all right that's okay
miss defranco
where were you
on the day of the incident
i was at the farm
had you spent the night there yes well
no
no we were at the
bed and breakfast down the street
because my daughter's room was
deemed um
unlivable i guess by the um
fire marshal or whomever the the
building department
so her your daughter's living
arrangement was impacted by what the
town did with respect to the buildings
oh yes she had to leave okay
and did you come back to the farm that
day yes
and uh
did you have uh
an instance to be sitting in the arena
yes and was that the indoor arena or the
outdoor indoor arena
okay
where were you sitting
i was sitting in michael's chair so the
door that walks out from the club room
into the indoor arena there are a bunch
of director's chairs if you were going
to the immediate left of that door the
first chair
that's the one i was sitting in and
that's when michael typically sat in
and
um
did who were you sitting with if anyone
nobody i was watching my daughter um she
had finished up riding her horse and
she'd already left and i was just
sitting there
did you encounter michael while you were
sitting in the arena in his chair
yes
did you make any observations of michael
at the time you encountered him while
you were sitting in the arena on the
morning of the incident in his chair yes
he walked out what were your
observations i'm sorry it's okay a
question is better than we get a
question and answer yeah sure okay um he
was totally absent catatonic
he didn't even know i was sitting there
did you try to speak with him yes
and did he acknowledge you no
with respect to what you observed that
was happening at the farm
did you develop
any understanding as to
whether there was some
systematic steps against mike
objection
you're referring to your observations of
michael that day
did he appear normal to you no
did he appear healthy to you no
did you have any concerns about his
safety as a result of your observations
of him that day
absolutely he looked suicidal
i don't have any further questions at
this time
all right cross-examination mr shellhorn
mr franco how many horses did you have
at the property in summer of 2019 i had
one my daughter had two
you said that your daughter is still
competing
yes what is her level that she competes
at
she
competes at intermediary one
is that as an amateur or a professional
or special
professional so your daughter is a
professional uh equestrian
my daughter uh switched her status from
amateur to professional when she started
working for michael because those are
the rules and so even though she does
not currently she's not currently
employed
in the equestrian community she
maintains her professional status
because that's
the level she rides at
so she rides at a high level yes she
does
now you indicated that on august 7th
2019
you were at the
farm or at the barn with your daughter
yes
and you and your daughter were in the
process that day of making arrangements
to leave the farm correct
you indicated that you were looking for
another farm to take your three horses
to yes
and you said that you had
a lot of concerns in those weeks leading
up to august 7th yes
but you hadn't actually made the
arrangements and actually taken the
horses off the property at that point
yet had you no we had an appointment
and that would require you going to meet
with various different
farms or barns yes and you would have to
i think you had said
you were looking for another barn to go
to that was safe and clean yes so you
wanted to make sure that you were
vetting out the place where you were
going to take your horses that it would
be appropriate for them yes as well as
for your daughter
based on her aspirations as a writer
at that point it had nothing to do with
riding or training
we wanted to get the horses off so we
weren't looking for a trainer per se we
were looking for a place for the horses
to be housed
but even in spite of that it did take
effort to try to find a place that would
be appropriate for your horses there are
several places at the area
were you aware of any of the specific
health conditions related to ms canarack
or mr goodwin's horses
if you i'm sorry just if you're aware
personally or had any awareness of that
no
um you didn't ever hear
ms canreck ever make any physical
threats
to whom
well you you indicate myself or to
somebody else
that's a fair question
you indicated earlier you were
interviewed on the day of august 7th
2019 yes you were interviewed by two
detectives detective boasts and detected
midosfelder yes and that was at the barn
yes
and they asked you during the course of
that interview whether you had heard any
physical threats made
to michael barrissone and you said no no
and you don't have any personal
knowledge of what happened by the
farmhouse on august 7th 2019.
i wasn't there
at the on camera you didn't see what
happened i wasn't on the patio no no i
wasn't trying to trick you uh no further
questions your honor
all right any redirect
uh no redirect your honor fine man thank
you you may step down thank you
if i call your next witness please uh
the defense calls stephen parches
[Music]
even porsches to the stand please
[Music]
please remain standing for a minute sir
you need to be sworn uh place your left
hand on that bible
please raise your right hand my court
clerk will administer the youth do you
swear in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony gives to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please station you must by
your last name for the record stephen
the last name is spelled t as in thomas
a-r-s-h-i-s
you
mr tarshish
good morning good morning what do you do
for a living i'm an attorney and how
long have you been engaged in the
practice of law
um 35 years
can you give us
your educational background uh certainly
i went to a city university in new york
attended law school at syracuse college
of law
and graduate school at nyu
what was the graduate degree at nyu uh
it wasn't a degree i went for cost was
in tax okay
um
and uh
when did you first become licensed to
practice law
if you recall
1976 actually and and i'm licensed both
in new york and new jersey it was um
76 in new york and i believe 80 in new
jersey and with respect to your practice
in new jersey
do you have any sort of focus with
respect to your work
um
when i'm asked that question i usually
describe myself as a business
transactional lawyer
but over the last
five or ten years
i've developed a somewhat unique
specialty in equine law
what is equine law if you could briefly
describe that for the jury uh basically
it's providing um
the horse community and people involved
in horse businesses whether they be
amateur owners professional riders
breeders trainers
both on the sports side as well as the
racing side
have very many of the same business
issues as most businesses
buying and selling horses
importing breeding situations
syndications of racehorses and sport
horses
unfortunately at times sometimes
litigation so because of the
unique nature of the people and the uh
the rules that are associated with the
sport
uh a
specialty of i suppose very few
attorneys who do it has arisen and
i'm one of them
does your has your specialty and your
past experience ever touched upon
uh the issue of
boarding arrangements for horses and
training arrangements for people oh
quite frequently
could you briefly describe your
experience in those areas well
many of the clients i've had are on both
sides i have clients who are operators
of
equestrian boarding facilities
commercial facilities
so they will have come to me they will
come to me i should say
to prepare boarding agreements for the
people who board their horses with them
setting out the rules the terms and
conditions under which
the owner and operator of the equine
boarding facility
will care for and take care of a
person's horses and on the other side of
that
it's the person who has a horse and they
want to
place their horse in the care of an
equine facility so they will ask me to
review frequently a boarding agreement
to make sure it's fair and equitable and
that
their horse is going to be well cared
for and their rights are going to be
protected so
it's like any contract transaction that
will be
on both sides of the of the transaction
in a boarding situation a specialized
form of contract yes very specialized
uh
do you know michael barroso yes i do how
long have you known mr barrison
somewhere between 10 and 15 years i
think at this point
and
how did you first come to know mr
barrison
i first came to know him as a trainer
i was training with a uh a young woman
who was a
uh
whom michael was a mentor she was a
professional
and she would frequently uh for her own
benefit take lessons with michael
and she introduced me to him and over a
period of time
seeing his skill and ability and what he
was able to do and aware of his
reputation i began to take lessons with
him as well
well so let's take a tangential turn and
topic for a second um are you also a
horseman yes i am okay and how long have
you been pursuing horse-related uh
activities over 30 years
do you consider yourself to be a
hobbyist a professional something else
what do you consider yourself to be
my time would say i'm a professional the
fact of the matter is i'm an amateur
it's it's something uh people who are
involved in the sport in a serious way
understand it's a different kind of
sport it's not a hobby it's not like
golf where you play and you put your
clubs in the closet it's a becomes a
matter of a full-time commitment as it
is for me is it a passion for you oh
most definitely
i ride at least five times a week i
devote at least 15 hours a week
uh to it i compete um
up and down the east coast and i've been
doing it for many many years
it might sound like a naive question but
that's what we're here for to get a full
explanation you ride do you also own
horses yes they do
over the years how many horses have you
owned oh god
well i have both sport horses and race
horses
the interest in racehorsing is a little
different it's
it's common for there to be what's known
as fractional ownership in racehorses
unless you're a very big
um very very
frankly very very wealthy or
run the business most racehorses are
owned by
three or four or five people
sport horses are usually owned
individually over the years i've
probably had
15 or so
horses that i've ridden and competed
with
and probably 10 or so race racehorses in
which i've had an interest
and is there a particular area of
horse sports that you focus
at the present time i've i've competed
in the three major disciplines of ending
show jumping and dressage for the last
10 to 12 years it's been dressage
and was it dressage that brought you to
michael yes it was okay and
what was it about
michael's reputation that made you want
to train with him
um
like any teacher
the ability to communicate
to a student is what makes in my view an
exceptional or good teacher and michael
had a very very
uh gifted way of communicating a very
very difficult sport and making it
understandable so that amateurs
such as myself would be able to learn
and progress he had a gift for
commission for communication and a
tremendous empathy for the horses of
course
did michael train your horses too no he
did not okay
uh but he trained you correct okay
and your experience with training with
michael did you ever uh witness him
riding horse oh absolutely sure many
times in all the times that you
witnessed uh michael using a horse
riding a horse did you ever see him do
anything harmful to the horse
no absolutely not
michael um
considers his horses gifts from god he
would i think that might have been a
quote even he treated them
as the as most horse people do um very
special and
preachers to be cherished and he was if
anything very very indulgent but never
abusive
so he was your trainer
and was he uh
did you still have a training repardon
did you still have a training
relationship with him
in the summer of 2019
not really um
i say that not really because the the it
was intermittent normally when you have
a trainer as i do now it's a consistent
relationship where you train with the
certain person
you know on a daily basis uh with
michael it was an occasional clinic or
an occasional lesson so i i can't say it
was really you know if i had called it
michael and said i wanted a lesson i
would have had a lesson but i didn't do
it so there was no not a real training
relationship at that point
over the years that you worked with
michael and knew him did you develop a
friendship with him
yes definitely well tell me about your
friendship with michael over those years
um
it was very soon there after we i
started
taking lessons and training with him uh
michael and i
for whatever reasons had a real empathy
with each other we kind of connected
both mostly through the love of the
horses
um
we're also to be very candid somewhat um
unique in the sport in the sense that
dressage particularly is a sport
dominated by women
i know for a fact
that 90 percent of the members of the
united states dressage federation are
women
so men don't usually participate in the
sport
so
you know that was uh
kind of we draw each other to because we
were kind of you know oddballs in the
sport and even though he was a
a
you know
a tremendous successful you know
international reputation professional i
was a
lousy amateur you know that kind of
brought us together and we just liked
each other and got along and enjoyed
each other's company
did you socialize with them oh yeah did
you socialize with them at the farm in
long valley yes
um
did there ever come a time
when he became your client for purposes
of legal services yes they did
okay and uh
when did he first become your client for
legal services if you recall i'm not
asking you to tell us anything about the
specifics of this over 10 years ago but
i couldn't
i'd have to go look at my files and and
see when you know the first matter might
have been but it's
i'm sure 10 years ago at least
so over that decade
how would you describe your professional
relationship as his attorney was it
intermittent constant something else
well the work would be intermittent
because it's not the nature of something
that comes up every day
but
in my mind
i believed he considered me his attorney
whenever a legal matter of
was
anytime the services of an attorney were
needed he always called me but it could
be three or four months could pass or
two weeks could pass or six months could
pass there was no consistency to it it
was when they need a rose
so but i i
i'd like to think i certainly did think
that he thought of me as his attorney
well let's move specifically to the time
period of july 2019 or actually let's
start it in june
through the day of the incident you're
aware that an incident occurred on
august 7 2019 yes i am all right so
from june of that year to the date of
the incident
uh
did michael contact you uh requesting
your services
yes he did
and was it
a matter you had previously consulted
with him on or something new something
new
without
revealing any client conferences
confidences
what was the subject matter of that
engagement
he called me to tell me that he had a
a client um
object that it's
let's not get into the specifics of what
was said
i understand so the question would be to
describe what the matter was but without
using someone's words i understand of
course i do
um the purpose for which he called me
was
um
that he
um
he had a problem with a particular uh
a border
who he wanted to leave the farm
and uh the person would not leave
that's as simply as i could put it it
was much more complicated than that but
that's about as simply as i could state
it did michael identify to you that
border did my name you mean yes yes and
who was it the lauren canary
following the time when michael
called you
to engage you on this new matter
uh
did you come to the farm
yes
do you recall coming to the farm in late
july of 2019
i was at the farm several times and
certainly in late july okay
do you recall um
having uh
conversations with michael
about the matter that you were
representing a mom with respect to
lauren canara yes i did
did any of those conversations
uh
occur
in public areas such as well let's
specifically did any of those
conversations take place in the locker
area of the barn
i don't
recall any taking place there there were
so many conversations
i know where the vast majority of the
conversations i could save with certain
took place but i don't have a specific
recollection of anything in the locker
area
um are you personally familiar with the
locker area yes i am let me show you a
photograph that was moved in evidence
says 800-42
let me know when you've had a chance i
know it very well
does that photograph accurately depict
how the locker area looked when you were
on the farm in uh the late july early
august time period of 2019 yes it does
is there a bench in that area
no and there was no bench there
now you said you could recall where
certain conversations took place did you
say the vast majority
correct
and
what's your recollection as to
where the vast majority of your
conversations with michael took place it
was an area that was referred to as the
lounge area
and uh
where was the lounge area located
it was the center of the of the um of
the farm or the building that the
comprise the stables and the barn
was the lounge area
uh
the club room
uh it was the club room i can
tell you uh
this this staircase here
if you walked up this staircase there
was a door here and if you walk through
that door you entered into the lounge
area the lounge area was when you came
to the front
of the entrance to to the farm there
were double doors and if you open the
double doors there's a very very very
large room that was the lounge area in
that area was a kitchen area
and then there was a huge pool table and
in the center of the area
was couches and
seats the reason it was there was
because there was a
a glass wall
and which was not unusual for a lot of
horse facilities
the idea was that
clients and friends could sit in the
lounge area look through the glass and
watch
you know their kids their husbands their
mothers their daughters watch them ride
so that was the that was a
pretty obviously the purpose of the
lounge area and that's where because it
was the largest area at the farm and
very comfortable obviously with couches
and chairs in a kitchen where people
would congregate and that's where the
vast majority of my conversation with
michael took place
was warren canorack ever present in the
room when you had conversations of that
nature with michael barrison no
absolutely not
did there come a time
in late july or august preceding the
incident
that you became concerned that your
private conversations with michael
barissone were somehow being overheard
by lauren kenorak yes excuse me yes
what happened that gave me that concern
well
unfortunately
this had dragged on the whole incident
and getting worse and worse almost by
the day
and given the very very almost
but
incestuous nature of the horse world
what was going on at the farm became
common knowledge within the horse
community so there's a tremendous amount
of social media
being posted about this stuff and i
believe
i heard it from so many different
sources but i believe i first became
aware that she was claiming to have
heard conversations i believe i first
became aware of it through postings on
social media
was robert goodwin ever in the room when
you were having private conversations
with michael about the matter no i've
never met god rob a good one never seen
him
did you ever see any social media
postings
um
with respect to what was going on at the
farm oh god yes
uh prior to the incident yes
uh how did you obtain access to those
postings well i'm not a social media
person but they would be pointed out to
me by michael
and mary haskins gray
uh justin uh harden might have done it
you know a lot of this i don't remember
specifically the source after you know
it was such a chaotic time and so much
was going on so i can't necessarily pin
down where it might have heard something
i just know i heard it and these are the
likely places that i from whom i would
have heard it
with respect and then i would go look
and see for myself yeah
so with respect to the postings that you
saw
did you see any that reflected words
that you had spoken in private to
michael yes
how many such postings did you see i can
only i one
particularly stands out because i was so
stunned
it was
really disturbing because it was like
you know it's like somebody was in the
room like she was in the room
and i and it was very it was very it
the only way she could have known it was
somehow by hearing it because it was
such a narrow specific conversation it
wouldn't have been something that would
have been passed along
to other people in idle gossip a
conversation
so you used the pronoun she in that
description to whom are you lauren
kendrick i'm sorry
lauren canary
did there come
have lauren
robert goodman and her horses leave
michael barason's farm yes
and did you make any
uh arrangements for
lauren cataract and her horses to go to
another barn yes i did
what arrangements did you make
um
understand i never spoke to a long
counteract
and i had never met coran farrick until
actually something that occurred
recently
but i never saw her didn't know her
i only spoke with her father jonathan
canorack and he and i had
well without getting into the spoken
words i'm asking you what arrangements
well i'll tell you
he and i spoke about
um negotiating negotiate an arrangement
whereby she would voluntarily
leave the farm so that other
um
judicial means to have her remove would
not be necessary
and that's what we talked about a
negotiation of those terms
so that she would leave
did you identify a specific farm where
she could go yes i did
was there a specific trainer involved
with that farm yes there was
was that trainer
in some manner uh
equal to the level of training that
michael could offer yeah objection
what's the basis for the objection
i don't think there's a there there's a
foundation for that question judge
it also calls for his opinion and i'm
not sure what the relevance of that
opinion would be here
let's take another
question yeah i'm not sure what the
relevance of his opinion is but
certainly the arrangements that he made
is something you can get into okay
so uh
that trainer
was it an olympic level trainer
um had won a gold medal at the pan
american games
equal to an olympic rider yes and did
that trainer have a facility
uh with us
similar to michael's
absolute equal to
and it was approximately 15 to 20
minutes from the long valley location
where uh michael's farm was and did that
trainer have stalls available for lauren
canarax horses yes
and
uh
did you communicate that information to
jonathan kanarak yes i did and i
communicated the individual's name who
was known to both lauren and her father
following the time when you communicated
that to jonathan kenorak did you have an
understanding as to whether or not there
was an agreement that lauren and her
horses were going to leave michael's
farm objection
let me see that sidebar please
the objection sustained rephrase your
question counsel
it's a narrow question
i don't remember the question at this
point
yeah he's gonna he's gonna rephrase the
question
go ahead counsel
in your negotiations with jonathan
canorack
what was your perception of his role in
those negotiations
i'm
being a lawyer and having to answer
these questions sometimes is a challenge
because i'm kind of monitoring myself
right
now no no i i understand i understand
his role was
to speak on our behalf to find a place
that she found acceptable
based upon her own standards her own
requirements where she therefore would
voluntarily leave michael's farm and go
to
another location
and his role was to negotiate the terms
that would be acceptable to her
did she leave the farm no she did not
did there come a time
after those negotiations occurred
that you wrote a letter
uh
providing some sort of notice to lauren
cataract
well um i'm confused because you're
leaving out a piece um
we negotiated an understanding
i believed uh my me i believe we had an
agreement election judgment well it's
his it's his understanding that was the
basis for the last objection that we
addressed at sidebar i know but that
that's
i'll allow that it's it's his
understanding based on his interaction
so it's it's
sufficient
without anything more it was his
understanding there was an agreement
what's your next question
i'd like to show you what's been marked
for identification as defense exhibit
700-3
why don't you take a moment and look at
that
so
uh
okay yeah
okay
you've reviewed exhibit 700-3
yes i have
uh
without do you recognize what that is
yes i do all right is that a letter you
drafted yes it is and was there a date
on the letter that you drafted august
5th
go ahead ask your next question this
particular copy i've shown you is
unsigned
do you agree
yes it is did you cause a signed copy of
this letter to be delivered to lauren
kanarak and john goodwin absolutely
robin goodwin robert giblin robert
no to jonathan canary and to lauren
cataract there we go
not to rob a good one okay
uh in and and
did you
give lauren canorack notice that she
needed to vacate the farm
that's what was the purpose of the
letter yes
i moved 700-3 in evidence
i would object judge there's been
testimony about it it's hearsay
but the objection sustained but
questions counselor you can ask
questions about the content of the
letter
can you tell me
uh specifically
uh
from your own recollection
the dates
or dates when you were having these
negotiations with jonathan canorack
it would have been
the friday preceding this
which i guess would have been on the
second i suppose
yeah and the week
at least the week before that and maybe
even the week prior to that it went on
for some time
so when you say the second you're
referring to august 2nd 2019 yes and
you're saying that it was occurring on
that date as well as potentially the
week before yeah i mean the specific
dates of course are days i can't
remember but i know we had several
conversations and it took quite a bit of
back and forth
to get to the point where i thought we
were on the friday preceding this letter
and
do you recall giving lord canorack a
specific
date and time by which you were
demanding on behalf of michael barrasson
that she vacate the premises yes i do
and what's your recollection august 7th
wednesday august 7th
and
did you cause this letter to be
delivered to warren cataract i think i
asked that but if you could just say
again yes i did and on what date did you
call it to be delivered to her
um
i can't recall i can only assume it was
the day that
it was delivered by email so it would
have been delivered the date it was it's
dated august 5th august 5th is the date
correct okay
uh was michael aware that you were
sending this letter
oh yeah
did michael express to you any concerns
about sending this letter yes he did
what concerns did he express to you he
didn't think she would leave
subsequent to
the delivery of that letter
did you
proceed
with any
actions toward
legal proceedings against
lord canarak and rob goodwin to have
them vacate the farm
yes they did and i have to confess at
this point my memory is a little fuzzy i
did what i said i was going to do and i
initiated an eviction proceeding
which
um
uh and she was served with uh
a complaint and eviction
let me
show you what i've marked for
identification as
document 700-5
could you review that for yourself
now
oh there's no question thing i'm just
asking you to review it
okay yes
so uh you've reviewed exhibit 705
correct
yes let me show you what i've marked for
identification as exhibit 704
please review that and let me know when
you're ready i know when i'm ready i'm
ready
you're ready now yes okay
um
what is exhibit 704
this is an affidavit of service
uh of the
eviction complaint
uh on
lauren counteract what is exhibit 705
the verified complaint
uh uh which was served uh pursuant as
reflected by this affidavit of service
do you have a refreshed recollection as
to the precise date when the eviction
complaint was served on lauren cataract
um yes or no yes what's your refreshed
recollection august 6th
okay
thank you i'll take these
in connection with
spending time with michael in the time
period from july 31st through august 6th
uh
did you notice
any changes in his affect
well the change that i noticed preceded
those days but certainly
be very much so in those days yes let's
move it back further then let's take it
from july 15th were you were you uh in
michael's presence in july of 2019. yes
i was
did you notice changes in his affect as
it got closer to the date of the
incident absolutely
excuse me absolutely
what were your observations
he became
very very upset um
almost to the point of
being unable to function
as an attorney and this was my client
it got so bad i couldn't even have a
conversation with him he was um
in constant fear
of so many things and all he would talk
about he was in a loop
all he would do was talk about the fears
that he had
and and here i am trying to be a lawyer
to a situation and proposing
solutions or possible paths to take and
he wouldn't deal with him he it was
difficult to have a conversation with
him he was constantly agitated
um
at times he was incoherent
um
it got so bad that i threatened to quit
i said i'm not serving any purpose
you're not listening to me you're not
hearing me
um
i i remember having you know screaming
at him i scream at him not him yelling
at me because i was so upset that he was
just ignoring me i don't think i
realized at the time
you know how out of it he was uh and it
only perhaps was later as we got really
close to the sixth and seventh when he
became just
you know non-functioning just completely
you could couldn't function
so the fears
relate to lauren cataract totally for
long camera
he was afraid that
um aside from her objective
sustained okay
based upon your uh
professional relationship with michael
uh did you have uh
an understanding as to
his finances
oh yes
uh
and did you have an understanding as to
michael's network
um
i had a
a pretty good idea i don't think i would
say i had a you know a really um exact
or precise understanding but i knew he
was very very unique
in the horse world how is he unique in
the horse world
um
again bearing in mind and it's hard if
you're not part of this community this
is an incestuous community where
everybody knows everything
and michael was unique that he was
successful businessman
i mean they're with all due respect to
their professional accomplishments
they're olympic writers who don't have a
nickel to their name they rely on
sponsors to support them michael had
accumulated
wealth in the millions
and it's just not done he was a very he
was a brilliant businessman
i have no further questions at this time
what
close examination
mr tarshish do you have any awareness of
what michael barrasson's monthly
expenses were no
do you know anything about how much it
cost them to run the two farms they own
no or pay payroll no
take care of the horses no
now you were asked a question by mr uh
dininger
about being contacted by mr barrissone
with respect to the issue with ms
canorack correct
do you remember when you were first
contacted about that
precisely no i don't
the best i could tell you
it was
either late june or the early part of
july
because my reaction was
when he spoke to me he had told me of a
situation that had been gone ongoing for
months
my reaction was why didn't you call me
sooner so i think it was late june or
early july so you think he contacted you
somewhere
a month to six weeks potentially before
the shooting could be yeah
do you have records of that
no
you were his lawyer
yes
and this was ongoing you had been
representing him for approximately 10
years or so at that point on and off yes
and he contacted you about a issue that
he had with this border and wanted to
take action
yes
you weren't aware of any specific
written contracts that mr barristone had
with ms canorack related to their
business arrangements i was aware there
was no written contract
now if i could just ask you
uh judge me i approach yes
[Music]
mr tartus i'm just showing you again
what's been marked as 705 and 704
and i'm just trying to get the the
timeline right sure
704
is an affidavit of service
correct and does that indicate that it
was served on august 6 2019 at 11 53 a.m
yes it does who fills this out
uh the person who's whose signature
appears the person who actually served
the document upon miss cataract
and is that based on something that you
would have given to that person or that
company to serve
i would have given them the complaint to
serve they would have served it and then
as a consequence of them serving it they
generate from by themselves this
document it's not a it's not a form that
i give them and they fill in they
they use their form and provide it to me
okay so if it says here that the papers
that were served on that day and time
was a
letter i guess you're saying that would
be wrong
uh i don't recall um
this complaint was never filed
oh it was never filed
that's right okay
so you sent a copy of the verified
complaint
unfiled
to ms canorack
they'll stop you i'm sure
michael did not want to start eviction
he wanted to scare her into leaving
so we suggested
serving her with the papers but not
filing them hoping
this alone would give her the impetus to
honor the agreement we thought we had i
understand so that that was my going to
be my follow-up question was that mr
deininger showed you
705. yeah there's nothing even filled
out on this thing
that's what i wanted to ask you right so
okay so this is a complaint that's not
filed correct
i understand and the purpose of sending
it was for michael barissone to scare
lauren kanorak into thinking that he was
serious or something for that effect
exactly
no further questions judge
all right you may step down sir thank
you can i redirect i'm sorry all right
let me step down mr tortious thank you
what do you have another witness counsel
can i check that
sure
[Music]
what
joe williams
joe williams
hi mr williams come on up to the witness
stand just remain standing place your
left hand on the bible if you would
raise your right hand my clerk will
administer another
juror
if you could fix that please
thank you sorry
do you want the presence of almighty god
that the testimony gives to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes ma'am please state your name
and spell your last name for the record
uh joseph williams
w-i-l-l-i ams thank you
have a seat mr williams please keep your
voice up nice and loud that microphone
does not project your voice and only
records yes sir if you don't understand
the question please indicate that and i
will have counsel rephrase yes sir all
right go ahead mr williams has been
sworn
mr williams my name is chris dininger
what do you what is your profession
currently i am a barefoot horse trimmer
and i train horses young horses and
behavioral issues
and uh do you operate that business in
new jersey yes sir
uh what town
uh
i travel okay
um and do you also live in new jersey
yes sir great
um
have you always worked in a horse
related field no sir
uh well what have you spent your time
doing over your career
i am retired uh detective sergeant from
township of berkeley heights
so a police officer yes sir detective
sergeant detective sergeant how many
years did you serve in law enforcement
uh 25 years
uh what type of work did you do in law
enforcement as a detective sergeant
we handled everything from
a bad check to
you know
every kind of case possibly uh
burglaries uh car thefts a little bit of
everything
drugs yes sir
contraband yes sir
and do you recall what year it was that
you retired from the police force sure
do
february 1st of uh 19.
february 1st 2019.
now mr williams
um
what did you ever perform services as a
farrier
i was a farrier
um trained as a farrier but i took my
business all barefoot okay
um did you ever uh well do you know
michael barissa yes sir
and what capacity do you know he was a
client i i was kind of he was a client
of mine for approximately five to six
months
okay and when was that client
relationship with him
um approximately
uh
february of 19 to
august july or august of about 19.
was michael aware of your service in law
enforcement
yes he was
did there come a time
in
late july
of 2019 that michael called you
yes sir
and
i don't want you to talk about the words
that were spoken in the phone
conversation
but what was your understanding as to
why he was calling you
your personal understanding as opposed
to what was spoken
understanding was you call me in
reference to
having a problem with
a client who also resided on the
property
and about
the situation between him her and her
boyfriend
did michael ask you for any advice with
respect to the situation
yes he did
based upon
your communications with michael in that
phone conversation
did you have any concerns
about what was happening at the farm
i don't know if i had concerns i gave my
input on what i would do
what input did you give him
i advised him to
[Music]
go down to the municipal court and file
um harassment complaint i told them to
go down to the uh they're going to have
them fill out a probable cause statement
given the facts and see if there's
enough justification to
you know file a charge
and i told them to you know
retain an attorney not for that but as
far as him advising me he had problems
with
evicting her from the property
did you communicate to him anything
about
the risk of
someone putting something in the vehicle
yes and in reference to
um harassment complaint i also told them
you know if you're harassing her she's
gonna do the same thing
in reference to
the vehicle
i advised him after he advised me that
he thought she was on some sort of
narcotic i told him to keep his vehicles
locked
in in the event that you know something
could possibly potentially be
placed inside the vehicle to kind of set
him up
no further questions
false examination
am i being disrespectful if i call you
mister now that you're retired you can
call me whatever you want sir
just don't call me late for dinner
mr williams so so when michael barason
contacted you
so your advice was that he should go to
the municipal court and file a
harassment complaint yes sir
you also told him
generally walked him through the process
he could do to follow that yes sir
but you also told him that it was
possible that someone who was using
drugs may plant drugs in his car
potentially being due to the fact that
he was having uh
problems with this person
and he you know
he advised me that he thought or i don't
recall exactly the conversation but she
potentially could be using drugs so i
just told him to keep his vehicles
locked
but you would agree with me that someone
who's addicted to drugs
doesn't just go give up their drugs and
stick it in someone else's car to plant
it on them and get them in trouble i'm
not i've never done a drug in my life
i'm not a drug user but uh it makes
sense and fair to say berkeley heights
the the drug problem there
is not at epic proportions the way it is
in other places
we had our fair share but yes did you
have cases where people who were
addicted to drugs were planting drugs in
other people's cars i've had cases where
drugs were
put placed in someone's car
no further questions judge what
you may step down thank you sir
you want a break now yeah all right
we'll take our lunch break a little bit
early 12 uh 15 but uh we'll resume
around 115 or 120 somewhere around there
thank you
um
[Music]
all right good afternoon everyone please
be seated we'll continue
council call your next witness
your honor the defense calls
brian gibson
ryan gibson
just watch your step
mr gibson please remain standing place
your left hand on the bible raise your
right hand
go ahead
do you show the presence of almighty god
that the testimony given to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please state your name and
spell your last name for the record
brian gibson gibb sln thank you all
right have a seat mr gibson please keep
your voice up
that microphone does not project your
voice in a courtroom
so if you don't understand the question
just uh indicate that and i'll
counsel rephrase go ahead counsel
uh good afternoon mr gibson
yes i do um what profession do you
engage public insurance adjusting
what is the field of public insurance
adjusting sure
um public adjusting is where the
homeowner or business owner has an
insurance policy for property that they
own
they would hire me to represent them if
they had a claim
where an insurance company has
either
a direct employee of the insurance
company as an insurance adjuster
or they use independent insurance
adjusters to negotiate claims on their
behalf
is the field of insurance adjuster
a nationwide pursuit
and some states do not have public
adjusters you
they just don't exist but in new jersey
they do they do yes and do you have any
particular
education background that's relevant to
it well uh in new jersey you have to
have continuing education um through
online courses right
prior to being a public adjuster i was
electronic engineer
and then i switched fields 11 years
after that so my schooling is more
towards the electronic and and
experience more towards public adjusting
um so how many years have you been
engaged
in the business of being a public
insurance adjuster this is my 30th year
30th year yes
and you operate your own company yes uh
gibson and associates yes
um
with respect to how your office operates
i'd like to try if we can to direct your
attention to what your office operated
like
in january of 2019.
that's that time frame for the first six
months of that year okay
go ahead to answer your question um my
office is located in total in new jersey
we have a small office which we have a
secretary who happens to be my wife
and my boss if you want to look at it
that way
i have a business partner and my son
would be also an adjuster
with my firm and i think in 2019 that
that was the extent of our firm
okay
uh do you have a sophisticated phone
switchboard system in the office
we have approximately three lines coming
into the office um two of the lines are
mostly made for outgoing calls not to
tie up our office lines for new business
coming in
we found probably about 10 years ago
that it benefits our office if we have
that line forwarded to my cell phone so
we didn't miss any incoming calls or
wait for an answering service to get
back to us
because we found answering services kind
of didn't give us the correct names or
correct numbers or addresses they
weren't accurate so we all the phones at
that time were forwarded to my cell
phones
may i ask with respect to the practice
of being an insurance adjuster are
sometimes you called upon an emergent
basis yes but our licenses only
allow us to solicit or to
obtain new business between the hours of
8 am and 6 pm
for the first 24 hours of an incident
but if somebody called us and it was an
emergency as long as we get a call in
we're allowed to go out and take care of
that
situation and there is a licensed issue
too but we're licensed by the state
department of banking and insurance
is that something as to which you had to
submit an application yeah the submitted
application a form of insurance um
continuing education that your credits
were up to date
so uh
is a person or an operation vetted
before they're given that license yes
and you've been through that vetting
process yes and did you maintain that
license in january of 2019 oh yes have
you maintained it continuously
throughout your operation of your
business yes
let's go to
uh
january of 2019.
um
did you come into contact
with uh
michael barrisson yes
and
what was it that brought you into
contact with him
i believe i received a phone call from
mr barazon that he had a claim in a
farmhouse he owned uh
it was a pipe um
freeze up so it was a pipe that burst um
due to the thawing of the broken pipe
was that pipe uh that burst in a
farmhouse did you say yes and was that
the farm where michael also had his
dressage facility yes i i understand
that their
facility was
further back than the farmhouse i never
actually ventured
back that way okay but the farm house is
where i
my business took place okay
and um
so you get the call from michael you're
advised this of some incident and said
what was the next step you took with
respect to this contact so either the
same day or the following day i would go
down and meet um mr barriston and
look at what is involved with his claim
um see what caused the damages find out
whose insurance company he was with and
make sure that he had coverage for the
claim that he had
do you have a specific recollection as
to whether mr barristone was actually in
the state of new jersey when this claim
arose as opposed to being in the state
of florida i could tell you that i know
the claim took place on january 28th or
at least it was reported on january 28th
and i've been i was retained on i
believe january 31st
so i can't tell you if he was there
before we met i i don't know that can i
show you a document sure i've marked uh
our identification is 750 that's five
zero
let's learn what you think
take a moment to review this to yourself
okay
okay
do you recognize the document yes what
is it this is my firm's retainer
agreement
and does it indicate that you're being
retained into in connection with any
specific event pipe break
where
uh 411 west mill road and long valley
new jersey and does this uh document set
forth the terms of your agreement with
respect to acting as acting as an
insurance adjuster yes and do you get
compensated yes and what does it say
your compensation is in connection with
this engagement seven percent of the
settlement okay does this reflect your
signature yes and do you see another
signature yes whose is that
i i know it's mike barazone but i can't
read it because it's a signature but i
know that to be because that's uh who
retained me and does this the confirm uh
does this confirm the date when it was
signed
january 31st okay
2019. okay
so
do you recall where it was that you met
with michael to have him sign
in his kitchen the first floor kitchen
that's property so was there an active
water leak at the time you were there no
um the insurance company brought in a
company called code blue restoration
and what they did is set up fans and
dehumidifiers
to try to dry up the structure
um
so it wasn't actively leaking at the
time that i was there but i was able to
see
the pipe that broke where it was located
and the damage that it caused
so the efforts of that company would it
be fair to call them a remediation
company
and why is it important if you know to
have a remediation company come in well
very
the first part of your insurance policy
tells you that you need to protect your
property from further damage so by
protecting your property from further
damage you want to bring in a
remediation company
to dry up the structure to prevent mold
or any additional damage that may be
caused if you don't address the wet
material
do they sometimes cut into the walls
when they're attempting to dry it out
yes do they remove some drugs yes do
they remove insulation yes
and if they left that in place and
didn't remediate
uh what sort of additional damage could
happen to the property well the floors
would buckle more than they have
you develop a mold situation in the
walls
i do believe when i was at the property
and code blue was there
we did some testing and additional
sheetrock or drywall had to be removed
because it was wet and it wasn't
found at the time when code blue was
first involved
you recall i'm sorry were you done yeah
that's fine okay do you recall when you
were there whether or not the ceilings
have been stripped of their sheet rocket
insulation
some were some were not some i
instructed them to move further with the
the removal of the drywall and that was
to protect the property yes and does
that also in some manner
hopefully
reduce the claim yes
in connection with this claim
were you ever
uh did you ever
meet with lauren canorack
no
did you ever speak with lauren canorack
no
to your knowledge did anyone else from
your office ever meet or speak with
lauren cataract
no
how many claims
over the years all right i'll i'll
change the question
if you were to give a good faith
estimate right as to the number of
claims that you've been involved with
over the years
can you ballpark it would it be dozens
hundreds and thousands what would it be
approximately
200 250
claims a year
sometimes if there's
storms or or floods that come through
that number jumps dramatically so during
super storm sandy for example what
happened to your office we had to stop
taking claims we did so much business
that i had to instruct my firm to stop
uh
bringing a new business
it wasn't
fair to the client or the potential
client
and it would just
drive us crazy we so we had to stop we
only took so many
in your past experience
uh is a
damage to a house from a burst pipe
something that's unusual no
how common is it in your experience in
the winter months between
january and march very common
uh
ex for a free a frozen pipe for a pipe
break
it's could be
very common just for the pipe to break
by itself or or a pinhole or something
rubbing against a pipe that causes but
in this case
it was a frozen pipe
that when that pipe thawed that's when
the water
caused all the damages
was there anything unusual about this
claim based upon your experience of 30
years in the insurance adjusting
business no it was common
for this type of claim
do you know whether in connection with
investigating the claim and representing
michael or his business in connection
with it
whether you did anything to verify
whether there was a propane in the tank
on the property
so my firm directly does not get
involved with any investigation port of
the claim
but the insurance company did request
information
that i then asked mr perezone to provide
to us
one was to make sure and according to
this type of claim you have to make sure
that heat is maintained in the house
so they requested um information it was
a propane
propane supply the the fuel to heat the
the home
so they asked for
propane bills or documentation to show
that there was propane in the tank
at the time of the loss
with respect to this claim and the
communications with the insurance
company
were
the communications really through you
representing michael barrasso so the
line of communication would be from the
insurance company to me to mr barrisson
to mr barrison to me to the insurance
company
and the question about
documentation of having propane in the
tank that was one of those conversations
yes
let me show you what i've marked for
identification as defense exhibit 700-51
[Music]
yes
have you reviewed it yes do you
recognize it yes what is it this is from
the propane company that supplies
propane to the farmhouse okay
is it a delivery receipt yes
does it indicate how many gallons of
propane were delivered can i see you at
the bench please yes
i have no further questions for the
witness at this time would you like to
spend sir
oh yes certainly
mr shellhorn any cross-examination no
thank you judge all right you may step
down sir
[Music]
call your next witness the defense calls
philip ducking
mr dunton please remain standing place
your left hand on the bible please
raise your right hand listen to the oath
please do you swear in the presence of
almighty god that the testimony goes to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth i do please state your
name is by your last name for the record
uh philip dutton
d-u-t-t-o-n thank you
all right you may have a seat mr dutton
please keep your voice up nice and loud
okay
go ahead counsel
good afternoon mr dutton i live in
pennsylvania that's correct let's see
uh the postal address is west west grove
how long have you lived there
uh about 30 years
uh what do you do for a living
um what's called a three-day event rider
or equestrian so
um that's what i do full-time so i
compete um throughout the world and
teach and train horses
so you said a three-day event writer
that's what
am i using the term correctly correct
yes
uh could you give the jury a description
as to what that means
um a three-day event is like a triathlon
for horses so there's three sports um
involved in the one
in our sport and you can only use the
same horse for all three sports and
the score is tallied over the three
sports
so there's three sports at dressage and
then cross-country and show jumping
how long have you been engaged in the
pursuit of that sport
uh well i've ridden all my life i mean
you start off in pony club and that kind
of thing um but when i moved to this
country from australia i
took it up full time
how long ago was that
that was in 1990 i believe
you do it competitively correct
uh have you ever gone to the olympics
i've been to seven olympics seven yes uh
and uh
what country were you representing in
the seven olympics you attended
i represented australia in uh
atlanta sydney and athens and then i
changed my nationality to the u.s and
represented
us in
china and then london and then rio and
just recently in tokyo
have you meddled
yes i was fortunate to be happy
team gold medalist for australia twice
in a individual
uh medal for america in uh rio
de janeiro what year was rio 2016 2016
yes
do you know michael barrison
yes i do
how did you come into contact with him
uh michael is a great dresser driver and
teacher and
so i sought him out to get help for the
one of the disciplines which is dressage
um
leading out
around the london olympics time and
for a year or two after that
and if you could for the jury's sake
when were the london olympics
uh that was 2012.
so is it fair to say that as of now
you've known michael for maybe 10 years
that's correct
and you worked with him as a trainer
well he was my coach for dressage yes so
i was a student in that situation
okay so when you say coach he's coaching
you as a rider as opposed to something
else
he's coaching his rider but also the
horse and
uh giving his professional
wisdom on how to improve the horse and
get them to go better and train better
and muscle better and
just overall improve uh the performance
are those things impactful on your
performance in competition
absolutely yes and that's why you know
competition's tough so you're just
trying to get a little bit better all
the time so you seek out
help and advice
all the time did michael do that for you
yeah michael's great coach
so you know him as a coach
did he
fit
any other categories in your life such
as friend mentor anything else
yeah i'd call him a friend and uh you
know i
we didn't hang out that much
certainly on trips like going overseas
you usually only got one horse and that
doesn't take long so you hang out there
and talk and
uh get to know one another so i got to
know him pretty well even when he wasn't
coaching you know would still
um see him and around some of the
competitions even when he wasn't
coaching me i could still see him at
some of the competitions and talk and
that kind of stuff
have you ever seen him ride a horse yes
with any frequency have you seen him do
that
uh yeah i'd say i'd saw him ride he's
ridden some of mine to get a feel for
what they were like
in your experience
have you ever seen michael
do anything inappropriate with a horse
no never um you know at this level the
horses are unless they're treated well
they're not going to go well so
you know it's it's in no one's interest
to be
mean or
bad to a horse or do anything wrong to
them
so have you ever seen a mystery divorce
never
have you ever seen him
become violent toward another person no
i have not
have you through your interactions with
him
develop a belief as to his truthfulness
uh all of my interactions uh michael was
extremely honest and um
somebody that i could trust yes
did you find him to be honorable or
dishonorable in business
i think he's very honorable i mean i
didn't have much of a business dealing
it was just more uh paying i paid him
for my lessons and that kind of thing
but
it was he was very honest and
straightforward and
trustworthy
all right i have no further questions at
this time close examination yes judge uh
mr dutton good afternoon hi
i'm sorry to ask you this question uh
but
did you have a fire on one of your farms
in may of 2011. yes
and uh a number of horses
perished in that fire that's correct um
six to be exact
uh so is it fair to say that a a barn
fire can be very dangerous for the
horses
absolutely
and you weren't at mr barriston's farm
on august 7 2019
no
thank you sir no further questions judge
your own thank you sir you may step down
thank you
mike mcgrave
[Music]
hi please remain standing left hand on
the bible please raise your right hand
listen to the oath please do you swear
the presence of almighty god that the
testimony goes to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
yes please state your name as for your
last name for the record michael mcgrane
m-c-g-r-a-i-n thank you all right have a
seat mr mcgrane please keep your voice
up in response to questions okay if you
don't understand something that's being
asked please indicate that i'll have
counsel rephrase go ahead counsel
mr mcrae
where do you reside
i live in westminster maryland
do you have any involvement in
the horse industry
yes i uh
i train and work and teach
do you have a particular area of
training that you engage in for horses
uh dressage mainly dressage okay
do you know michael barrison yes
how did you come to know him
uh i met him a few years back and uh
went and ended up working for him as a
young horse rider
do you recall what year it was that you
met him
i think 2018.
we're just asking for your best
recollection yeah okay
um
did you uh
work at mr barristone's uh
farm in florida
yes
did you work at mr barristone's farm in
long valley new jersey yes okay
were you working
for mr barriston in 2019
yes
were you present
on his farm
commencing in june of 2019. yes and
that's the long valley farm yeah
did you have living accommodations there
i did i lived in a like an rv trailer
um
comfortable arrangement yeah i liked it
uh were there any particular
geographic formations in the nature in
the area where your trailer was
you may like the landscape or yeah
yeah i mean i was kind of a little
elevated um
above the barn up like a little slurp a
couple trees around me some big rocks
okay stuff like that
so
your job working for michael was to
train horses
yeah i did the young horses you know
mostly young horses
and did you have any other work that you
performed for him while you were working
for him yeah if i wasn't riding horses
i'd do um some construction work for a
little side money or something like that
um what experience do you have in
construction
i worked with my dad for about eight or
ten years doing uh home remodeling and
kind of high-end work and stuff like
that
did any of the work that you were
involved with involved tiling yes
what level of experience do you have
entirely
um after i spent a few years with my dad
i ended up kind of being like the main
towel guy i did all the laying
and stuff and
you know
all the laying stuff out and
everything like that
so how many years do you have of
experience working with ty
eight or ten eight or ten and let me ask
it might sound like a negative question
but
is that something that takes some skill
to do properly
yeah i've seen some pretty bad jobs from
people
okay
and so as a person with uh
seven or eight years of experience did
you have enough experience to do a good
job as opposed to a problematic one i
think so yeah
during 2019 do you recall what month it
was that you arrived at the farm in long
valley
in 2019 yes
do you mean when i started working there
or when i got back from florida when you
got back from florida would be the way i
would put
march or april maybe i think april
probably
and um
uh were you uh
involved in any of the work being done
to the farmhouse in 2019.
yeah
okay um were you involved at all in the
tile work in the basement of that
farmhouse
yeah it laid the doll in there you did
yes
did you work with anyone in laying that
tile i worked with rob
rob who rob goodwin okay
and uh
did to your knowledge
which of you mr goober you had greater
experience in file work i think in tall
work i did
did uh which of you took the lead role
on that job
uh
i pretty much did yeah
and
is there a percentage that you'd split
it up as to how much percentage you were
responsible for as opposed to mr goodwin
uh
i was responsible for probably 70 80 of
it
when you were
involved with working with mr goodwin
um
did he show up on time for work
um rarely
judge i'm going to object at this point
it's a little far afield council
did
the atmosphere at the farm change
in july of 2019
yeah
did you observe changes in the
atmosphere experience them yourself
uh yeah
what did you observe and experience that
were changes in the atmosphere at the
farm at that time
things got real tense it was not as much
fun working there anymore uh
seems like everybody was walking on
eggshells you know just
you know really nervous stuff like that
were you walking on eggshells
i started locking my doors
yeah
i was i was nervous
was that an unusual thing for you to do
yeah
from your perspective
was there a cause
for that change
yeah what was it
uh
objection
what's the basis for the objection
relevance judge speculation calls for a
lay opinion
our injection sustained
you mentioned a rock near the trailer
yeah
did you have
any particular use for a rock near the
trailer in your personal
life at the farm i don't know why i was
there but i like to sit out there and
smoke a cigarette
did there come a time
in
uh late july early august
when you were sitting out there one
evening with justin harden
yeah
did anything unusual happen while you
and justin were sitting out on the rock
uh yes
what happened
uh we kind of you could see
like a figure kind of going around in
front of windows and stuff kind of
sneaking around dressed on black
and then uh at one point i heard some
wrestling in the brush behind me
and i was kind of like what's that you
know and
said something adjusted and then all of
a sudden
lauren canara comes out of the brush and
no shoes on dressed on black with like a
black fail kind of thing i guess the
cover face or something
was it light or dark out when this was
happening it was dark
that same evening do you know whether
michael was out trying to
walk the yard so to speak it was on the
front porch of the barn i think
what was lauren wearing specifically
it's
uh i guess like a
it was just all black i'm not sure it
might have been like
a little dress or spandex on and stuff
no shoes
you know i couldn't tell you exactly
what she was wearing
based on the circumstances you observed
that night
did that clothing impact the visibility
of lauren kenorak
yeah what did it do to the invisibility
of lauren canary well it was all black
the only time that you could see her is
either when she was standing right in
front of me or when she was sneaking by
a window that had light shining through
and you see a little shadow figure
shooting by the the light
when you talk about windows with lights
shining through what building were those
windows in
the garage
was she wearing shoes no
did you have a chance to observe
uh michael
in
the days
well let me ask this first were you on
the farm when the incident occurred on
august 7 2019 yes
okay
in the days preceding that
uh did you interact at all with michael
uh every single day okay
and did you notice any changes in
michael in those days preceding the
incident yeah i mean like usually he's
pretty fun to be around telling jokes
like you know he's always involved with
riding horses or coaching us and stuff
we weren't getting any coach he wasn't
coaching us as much anymore
he wasn't riding the horses they were
supposed to he just seemed like
depressed and out of it
and stuff
did there come a time when uh michael
did anything unusual toward you that you
felt was out of character
he broke down to me a couple times at
one point he gave me a hug which i
thought was weird because we're not
we've never actually really hugged each
other
so was that the first and only time he's
hugged you yeah
were you ever to your knowledge
mentioned in social media posted by
lauren cataract
yeah
did you see postings that you
interpreted to be about you
can counsel
i have no further questions of the
witness at this time cross-examination
thank you judge uh mr mcgreen you were
at the farm on august 7 2019 yes
you didn't see what happened or what
transpired by the farmhouse
uh you were interviewed that night at
approximately 7 12.
uh i was interviewed that night i'm not
sure what time
and was that at the that was when you
were still at the property yeah there
were two detectives there yeah
and they asked you a series of questions
about what you knew about what had been
going on at the property recently
they asked you questions about michael
barrasson yeah they asked you questions
about warren canreck
yeah i believe so and you didn't say
anything to them the day of the shooting
about this story about lauren kenrick
jumping out of the bushes wearing all
black did you
uh
i'm not sure if i did or not
probably yeah i don't know
judge i wasn't provided a transcript for
this witness to show them so i can
either
ask for the jury to be excused and play
the video for him let me see you at the
bench
mr mcgrane were you shown a copy of that
statement before you came in the
courtroom today no
mr buenkis or mr dininger never showed
you a copy of what you said to refresh
your memory before you testified no and
again judge for the record it's a video
that the prospect all right
i get it he wasn't shown a video
here's your witness
and you don't recall
whether or not you ever said that during
your interview the day that lauren
kanreck got shot it was
two and a half years ago i can't
i can't recall what
i was asked or said
do you remember when the police officers
asked you questions about 9-1-1 calls in
the week or so leading up to the
shooting
not specifically i don't remember do you
remember that there were 9-1-1 calls
yeah the week leading to the shooting
yeah and were you at the property when
some of those calls were made yes
were you at the property when some of
the
occasions when the police came yes
and did you think that it was
overreacting to excuse me to call the
police
i hadn't i i didn't know the severity of
the situation that time so i wasn't sure
but on august 7th when you met with the
police after the shooting and gave them
a statement you told them that it was
probably a little overreacting by
calling the police i may have said that
i'm not sure if i
how i said it
do you also recall telling the police
that nobody knew where the
disagreement had come from
yeah i actually i don't even know how
the whole thing got started
in the first place
no further questions judge
all right can you follow up redirect no
you're right all right you may step down
sir thank you
just watch your step
so donning there any other witnesses
this afternoon
we've run out of witnesses for today
fine i understand you'll have some
witnesses tomorrow morning
yes your honor
right um members of the jury uh good
news and bad news the defense has um no
more witnesses for this afternoon they
do have witnesses tomorrow
good news is
you get to go home early today
so we'll pick it up tomorrow morning
same time
please don't discuss the case with
anyone
and
do you know how many witnesses you have
for tomorrow
we have two leg witnesses correct then
i believe from two leg witnesses and two
experts
all right and so we'll have a full day
tomorrow with two late witnesses and two
experts so we'll hear that testimony
hopefully tomorrow and then if the state
has any rebuttal
and remember ladies and gentlemen i said
this at the beginning you probably
forgot but on thursday morning we're not
going to sit
thursday morning one of the attorneys
has a prior engagement
the attorney tried to get it changed but
um was unable to do so and it's a prior
legal engagement with a higher court so
i don't have any authority to make them
change it
so
i have to abide by what the higher court
schedules they take priority over this
trial unfortunately so
the attorney is going to be tied up so 1
30 we expect to be able to start so just
uh keep that in mind we'll start
tomorrow all day hopefully get all those
witnesses done the state has any
rebuttal testimony we'll start that on
thursday afternoon
all right please don't discuss the case
you're free to go enjoy your afternoon
we'll see you tomorrow morning thank you
mr shellhorn with regard to that last
witness
yes do you want um
you